this video was made possible by
curiosity stream
sign up for the nebula bundle deal for
just 1479 at curiositystream.com
forward slash real engineering to watch
the other eight episodes in this
logistics of d-day series
when learning the history of d-day we
are most frequently met
with tales of valor of soldiers rushing
the beaches
our collective vision of that day opens
with the lowering of higgins boat ramps
on omaha beach
the fury and violence of battle taking
center stage
in this chaotic vision it's hard to
believe that what was happening was a
carefully choreographed plan
one that required hundreds of thousands
of people
laborers in factories merchant sailors
transporting goods across
treacherous oceans engineers dreaming up
novel solutions to new problems
and of course the military strategists
that conceived the invasion plans
each played their part in the lead-up to
d-day
by the end of july just a little under
two months after the first men came
ashore
675 000 personnel were ashore
with 150 000 vehicles 690 000 tons of
supplies
and 69 000 tons of fuel the planning
and background support required to make
this happen was
immense some of these men and supplies
were air dropped into the fields of
normandy
but the vast majority of these supplies
were brought ashore
by landing craft ranging in size from
the personnel landing craft
like the iconic higgins boat all the way
up to massive ships like the lsd
or landing ship tank these behemoths
could carry 18 sherman tanks or 33
trucks
with births for up to 217 troops
these ships would prove invaluable in
maintaining the supply chain
in normandy however the logistics of
direct beach supply
came with a host of potential and
inevitable delays
all of the landing craft like the
higgins boat needed shallow drafts to
allow them to get close enough to the
water's edge
to offload their cargo this made them
incredibly unstable and in rough seas
manny capsized some like the lsds
had ballast tanks that could be filled
or emptied to alter their draft
filling them to increase their draft for
the open ocean increasing the ship's
stability
and emptying them to decrease it and
come close to shore
yet even lsds faced logistical problems
arrive at low tide and you are racing
the tide while you unload your cargo
into deeper and deeper water arrive at
high tide and you are racing the tide as
it leaves you stranded
on the beach until the next high tide
arrives on top of all this
the vast majority of war material was
coming from the united states
aboard liberty ships these ships needed
deep water harbors to dock
without a harbour of this kind in france
liberty ships were forced to dock in
britain and transfer their goods to
smaller ships like the lsd
if these ships could simply dock in
france it would save a great deal of
time
and effort in this logistical supply
chain
sherberg was prioritized for this very
reason
its deepwater harbour was a key
strategic target
and the allies choice of normandy was
largely based on its proximity
to the contentant peninsula a peninsula
which could be cut off
from reinforcements from utah beach
westward
however this campaign would take some
time the allies needed a deep water port
as soon as possible without a steady
stream of supplies and reinforcements
the small allied beachhead risked being
forced back into the ocean
the allies were faced with a difficult
dilemma and their solution is one of the
most remarkable feats of the second
world war
two floating harbors were constructed
and towed
across the english channel to be placed
directly onto the beaches of normandy
one for the british and one for the
americans each with an equivalent
capacity to the port of dover
this is the story of the mulberry
harbors
harbors serve some key functions to
allow ships to unload their cargo in
safety
the first role a harbor must fulfill is
to act as a safe refuge
for the ships protecting them from the
chaotic weather of the sea
to do this harbors need large break
waters and other protection to halt
waves in their tracks
leaving the inner harbor relatively calm
next
they must provide water deep enough to
allow ships to more directly next to the
pier
and unload their cargo regardless of the
tide levels
two simple functions that often require
an immense
engineering effort dredging of the sea
floor to increase the depth of water
construction of large concrete
structures and general planning
often take years to complete yet the
challenge the allies faced was much
greater than a typical harbour
this harbour needed to be built in
complete secrecy
floated across the english channel and
assembled
in the middle of a war zone it was an
insanely ambitious plan
let's see how they did it before making
any detailed plans
the engineers would need detailed
surveys of the ocean floor
and this information was vital for the
design stage
surveying the ocean floor would inform
the designers where to locate
deep water offloading points for ships
how high
breakwaters needed to be to rest on the
ocean floor
and sit above the waves at all tide
levels
and finally it gave the vital seafloor
topology information
required to design a floating pier
flexible enough to deal with the rough
seas
and lay on the seafloor without buckling
and breaking
taking soundings while germans watched
and listened from the shore
was a job entrusted to the 7th and 12th
survey flotilla they made a total of six
trips on moonless nights between
november 1943
and january 1944 setting sail from cows
on the isle of wight
data was gathered in two locations here
to the east of omaha beach
the designated location for the american
harbour dubbed mulberry harbour a
and here to the west of gold beach the
designated location of the british
harbour
dubbed mulberry harbour b typically
three small
lcvp landing craft were towed by
gunboats across the channel
once they reached a point about 48
kilometers off the coast
they slipped their toes and began their
stealthy approach to the shore
these lcvps were modified with
underwater exhausts
to muffle the sound of the engine tarps
to allow the crew to work with
light without being seen from the shore
and each boat was equipped with echo
sounders to survey the ocean floor
along with the necessary navigation
equipment to match the soundings with
coordinates on the map
this work provided depth charts like
this one which gave the engineers the
information they needed
to accurately plan the layout of the
harbors
the first components they needed to
address were the breakwaters
these would provide shelter to both the
ships and floating piers contained
within
the breakwaters took several forms the
simplest being codenamed
corncob the allies had a huge inventory
of aging ships which were no longer fit
for use
planners sought ships that were at least
30 years old
like the first world war super
dreadnought hms centurion
a 25 and a half thousand ton ship which
had previously been used as a remote
control target ship
for naval aiming practice in the 1930s
it was scuttled as part of the
breakwater from mulberry harbour a
this was just one of 14 ships that
formed what was termed
a gooseberry at mulberry harbour a one
of these breakwaters was formed
at each and every landing beach
shielding the landing beach from the
worst of the waves
and allowing landing craft to unload
their wares in relative cam
the scuttled ships were also ballasted
and sunk in a manner that ensured their
superstructure remained above the water
line
in fact the crews of these ships had no
idea of their fate
as they set sail for normandy their
useful equipment was removed
two explosive charges were laid and they
were informed of their destination with
no further information
upon arriving and anchoring off the
beaches a wrecking officer
boarded their ship and detonated the
charges with the men still aboard
there the ships sank and the crew
members remained at action stations
providing valuable first aid refueling
and repair services
for the smaller boats under their
protection the next component of the
breakwaters the bombardons
were designed for deeper water the
designers of the mulberry harbors wanted
breakwaters placed
further from the coast which would
provide some protection to deeper draft
ships
like liberty ships which would unload
their wares onto smaller ships
to transport to the beaches these
breakwaters underwent
several design iterations namely in the
quest to reduce the level of concrete
and steel required to build them
building a structure that lay on the sea
floor in water this deep was not
feasible
so some innovative designs were trialled
one idea was a pneumatic breakwater
this idea proposed the use of compressed
air fed through perforated pipes
along the seafloor to create a wall of
air bubbles
that would block the motion of waves
this sounds like an
outlandish idea how could air bubbles
possibly block the immense power
of the sea two surface currents are
created with this method
one opposes the incident waves and the
other
inner harbor facing current has no
effect on the wave action
this was a tried and tested method of
creating a breakwater
this is a video of the effect in action
however it takes an enormous amount of
power to pump the volume of air required
against the pressure of water bearing
down on the pipes
estimates of the power required for the
two mulberry harbor pneumatic
breakwaters were placed
at an astonishing 3 million horsepower
this being rather obviously unfeasible
left the allies with one choice
a series of floating breakwaters waves
are
after all surface phenomenons and an
adequately designed floating breakwater
can provide shelter once anchored
sufficiently
rigid floating breakwaters were needed
these cross-shaped steel break waters
were chosen
as they minimized the quantity of steel
required
even still each one contained 250 tons
of steel
the bottom three arms were opened to
water while the top was enclosed
to allow it to float each was 60 meters
long and 7.6 meters in both width
and depth leaving large gaps between
these floating break waters was not an
option
as the waves would simply pass through
the gaps by diffraction
and rebuild themselves inside the
harbour with most of their energy
retained
during the design phase the engineers
tested a range of gaps
optimizing the area covered and the wave
transmission
and found a 15 meter gap was optimum two
rows of these break waters were more
250 meters apart which provided a
reduction in wave height
by 70 percent and reduction in wave
energy by 90 percent
these break waters were assembled about
two kilometers offshore for both
mulberry harbour a and b in the six days
after d-day
providing liberty ships some protection
as they offloaded cargo
to smaller ships capable of offloading
directly onto the beaches
the final line of defense was the
phoenix casens
these provided the brunt of the
protection for the harbour
these were essentially boats made of
concrete there were six
different sizes each tailored for the
depth of water they were designed to be
sunk in
the largest being the a1 type which was
18 meters high
24 meters wide and 63 meters long
and weighed an astonishing 6 000 tons
these larger casings even had
anti-aircraft guns attached
to provide anti-aircraft cover for the
harbour which was not needed in the end
each end of the phoenix casings was
upswept to allow for
easier towing across the channel the
lower level of the concrete boats
consisted of a series of water-tight
compartments
which were flooded to sink them in fact
once each casing was complete
the allies sunk them offshore to hide
them from german planes
until the time came to re-float them and
transport them
across the channel 147 of these phoenix
casings were manufactured on beaches
excavated basins along the thames and in
actual dry docks around britain
with a workforce of over 20 000 people
taking 150 days to complete
the massive breakwaters the skill of
these workers varied greatly
and as a result the concrete was of
varying quality
upon sinking many cases broke their
backs but at this stage it mattered
little
their purpose was to sit on the seafloor
but removal efforts would prove
difficult
and to this day many of these massive
concrete structures
remain in normandy the next portion of
the mulberry harbour design
the piers required vastly more
engineering forethought
they needed to function at high and low
tide and
every level of tide in between that's a
great deal of mechanical movement
along the length of the pier and that's
not even accounting for wave action
as the breakwaters couldn't feasibly
stop all waves from getting through
these structures needed to deal with
these forces and
managed to provide a steady roadway for
trucks
filled with supplies and tanks traveling
across it
it was a huge engineering challenge the
first structure needed was an offloading
pier
this couldn't be a floating platform it
needed to be rigid and stable
to accommodate the shifting weight of
trucks loading cranes and supplies
so each platform came with four legs
which could be controlled
independently of each other each leg
could be lowered
to the sea floor allowing the pier to
lie evenly on the surface
even if the sea floor wasn't even the
platform was capable of moving up
and down these legs at a rate of about
0.75 meters per minute
more than enough to quickly adjust to
tight levels the platform could float
but it was typically kept a short
distance above the water to keep wave
rocking to a minimum
around the four edges of these sput
piers were attachment points for
floating pontoons
that could expand the birthing space for
ships like this modular slipway designed
to allow
lsds to offload their cargo directly
from their front ramp
each spud pier also had eight bearing
seatings
to attach bridge spans to the pier these
bridge spans
were the next challenge the motion of
the sea would place rolling
pitching and twisting action along the
length of these bridges
if the bridge was not capable of moving
with the ocean it would inevitably break
apart
the bridge sections were relatively
stiff along their length
thanks to their h-beam design ensuring
the bridge spans could support the
25-ton
tanks that would be crossing them the
tapered h-beam design
where the side girders narrowed towards
the ends
also allowed the sections to accommodate
a great deal of twisting motion
up to 40 degrees along its length
essential for dealing with the rocking
ocean
the bridge sections were modular
allowing additional length to be added
by simply adding additional sections
this was achieved through spherical
bearings at each end
that slotted into seating in pontoons
called beetles
the bearings were designed to allow 24
degrees of deflection
between each section allowing bridge
sections to pitch
with the ways and accommodate up to 48
degrees slope
when laying directly on the seabed to
ensure the bridge sections were not
simply ripped apart
wire cables were attached to the beetle
pontoons and wrapped around a hole
in the girder's end section these
beetles like the phoenix casens
were primarily constructed with concrete
to save precious steel
only pontoons that would be laid over
the tidal zone
were constructed from steel and once
designated for rocky sections of tidal
zones
also came with adjustable spud legs
these flexible floating bridge sections
connected the spud piers to the
shoreline and allowed them to operate
through the full tidal range without
issue
with all of these components designed
tested manufactured
and hidden from site the allies were
ready as d-day approached
the various components were transported
to these locations
before sailing towards area zebra the
entrance point to the shipping lanes
the allies had cleared of mines just a
day before d-day
construction of the breakwaters began on
d-day itself
mulberry harbor a the american harbour
off the coast of omaha beach
was the first to begin and finish
construction the bombardance anchored
down
on june 6th and the first phoenix
casings were in place by june 9th
all corn cob ships were scuttled by june
10th
and the entire breakwater was finished
on june 11th
just five days after d-day by june 18th
four spud piers were completed and
offloading cargo
with two whale and beetle piers
connecting them to the shore
mulberry harbour b the british harbour
was slightly slower in construction
by june 18th the eastern pier was
completed
with four spud pier heads while the
center pier
and the lsd pier were partially
completed these structures were
protected by a partially completed break
water
only 25 of the 82 phoenix casings were
in place by june 18th
with no protection on the eastern or
western flanks of the harbour
june 18th is a pivotal date because on
june 19th
an unprecedented storm arrived in
normandy
and raged for two days winds tore down
from the northeast
through the strait of dover with waves
as high as 4.5 meters being reported
far exceeding the maximum design
expectation
of 2.4 meter waves it is said that this
was the worst storm the region had seen
in 40 years the american harbor mulberry
a
was completely broken beyond repair 21
of the 28 phoenix casings were destroyed
with four more
being badly damaged the whale and beetle
piers were smashed and twisted
by the lashing waves seven of the
thirteen blocked ships
broke their back while others sunk below
the waves as a result of the ground
below their hulls being swept away
bombards and ships alike had broken
their moorings and drifted ashore
sometimes crashing into the harbour
itself and causing further damage
mulberry harbour b by some miracle
avoided the worst of the waves
thanks to the natural breakwater of
brochures du calvados
located directly in the path of the
waves however
this did not save the bomber down
breakwaters located
further to sea these were broken apart
completely and manny came ashore to the
west of the harbour
while six of the 25 cases already in
place were destroyed
three of the four pure heads were also
damaged but not beyond repair
parts were scavenged from mulberry a to
not only repair mulberry b
but to strengthen it mulberry b soon to
be dubbed
port winston took whale bridges from
mulberry a
to construct a second store's pier an
lsd pier
and a shorter pier to allow rhino barges
to offload
by the end of october 40 000 vehicles
and nearly a quarter of a million
personnel
used this harbour to come ashore while
an average of seven
thousand tons of supplies were
discharged every day
an immense effort far exceeding the
original plants
in fact the harbour operated far beyond
its original operational target date
breakwaters were reinforced with an
additional 40 phoenix casings
this extra protection allowed port
winston to stay
in continual operation through the
autumn and winter
until its closure in december 1944
by which time the capture of sherborg
diep
ostend and antwerp made the use of
temporary harbours unnecessary
detractors of the harbours point out
that the us forces managed
just fine without the mulberry harbour
thanks to a greater than expected
performance
from the lsds and other landing craft
capable of supplying directly onto the
beach
omaha beach was managing 10 000 tons of
supply per day
at its peak while port winston achieved
6
750 tons per day at its peak this
criticism ignores the need for landing
craft in the pacific war
an upcoming southern invasion of france
not to mention that redundancy and
planning for the worst
is a vital part of war logistics with a
foothold in europe established the
allies could begin
streaming into the continent two months
of intense fighting in normandy
was fueled by these supply lines inch by
inch the allies scraped forward
but by the end of july the tides turned
the breakout arrived and the front line
began to race ahead of established
supply lines
operation cobra drove south towards
brittany reaching its border by july
31st
by august 7th brittany was overrun by
august 25th
paris was liberated and by september
15th nearly the entirety of france was
free
while the allies pushed towards the
german border but this rapid advance
brought with it
new problems supply lines from the
harbors to the front line were being
stretched
and they would be on the verge of
breaking until antwerp could be captured
the allies had been successful in their
campaign to [ __ ] german supply lines
prior to their invasion but this was the
very infrastructure they now need it
vital train supply lines would take time
to reconstruct
and the germans were readying themselves
for one final
massive counter-offensive the battle of
the bulge
this battle would test the allied supply
lines to the limit and without one
simple
but pivotal innovation the allies could
have been stopped in their tracks
the red ball express which is the
subject of the final episode
of the logistics of d-day series
available exclusively on nebula
this series has been a passion project
of mine for the past
nine months and the episode you watch
today has featured
tidbits from each of the nine episodes
we have an entire episode on why
normandy was chosen
which is also available here on youtube
the seven others are exclusive to nebula
and include episodes on the deception
tactics to keep things like the mulberry
harbour secret
an episode detailing the methods the
allies used to clear away
through the minefields of the english
channel and subsequently punching a hole
in fortress europe
an episode each for the amphibious and
airborne landing operations
one detailing the close air support
logistics where engineering battalions
rushed ashore on d-day to construct
new airfields another detailing the
insane oil supply pipelines
that were laid across the english
channel on d-day
this series which is over two hours long
in total
would not have been possible without the
funding and support
of curiosity stream and nebula the
streaming platform i created with over
100 of my fellow youtube creators
the best way to watch and ensure that
future projects like this can be funded
is by signing up for the curiosity
stream a nebula bundle deal
here you'll get a year's access to both
platforms for just
14.79 a year an insane deal that will
get you access to this series
ad-free videos from your favorite
youtube creators nebula exclusives like
tom scott's money
and access to curiosity streams
award-winning documentaries
like this one called hidden traces which
explores the scars of d-day
still present in normandy like those
massive concrete breakwaters
many of which remain in the shallow
waters of the sien bay
to this day for now we are taking a
break from this series and we'll begin
working on upgrading our animation
abilities
and researching for season two we want
to hear your suggestions
for the next battle we should focus on
but for now i am veering towards
covering the logistics of the battle of
britain
an aerial war that tested two nations
ability to not only build planes and
train pilots
but tested their wartime planning and
strategy a decisive battle that turned
the tide of world war ii
and prevented the germans from gaining
the air superiority needed
to begin their own amphibious invasion
of britain
if you want to see that please sign up
for the curiosity stream enable a bundle
deal
as always thanks for watching and thank
you to all my patreon supporters
if you'd like to see more from me the
links to my twitter instagram
discord server and subreddit are below